thank you how you doing
please thank you
wow you sound uh
that's very nice thank you very much
please
sounds almost like a full crowd that's
how good you are
and i appreciate you being here i
i think i know why you're happy today
you're breathing filtered air in here
that's
boy the the air quality out there
you live here not not good right
i looked at my phone and said that the
forecast for this weekend partly deadly
that's that's not something you want to
see on your phone and
i can tell that you know who doesn't
like it the animals i can tell do not
like this air the
in the midwest birds are falling out of
the sky last night i heard the coyotes
outside my window they were coughing at
the moon
it's rough i tell you every time i have
a car every time i got a cop i have to
think
is that cause i have a fire covert or
weed
thank you rodney thank you for that joke
i channeled him there but yes and the
government had put out a clean air
warning for
for sensitive groups so millennials
please stay inside
just kidding
oh the millennials might be pissed off
because trump has done it now
you know tick-tock right owned by the
chinese well the chinese
threat is history now he is shutting
down tick-tock he can't get it now
if you haven't you could have it forever
but if you can't get any new tick-tock
cause the chinese have been stealing our
dance moves
and that stops now but have i seen this
before
conservatives shutting down a place
where people dance isn't this the plot
to footloose
okay so well the
president uh trump quite a week quite a
week even for him
uh called biden a pedophile as you do
when you're running for president
but uh biden the head dueling tunnel i
thought biden looked pretty good in his
town hall last night
i did and and he's out of the basement
he's out there campaigning
he is he was in florida trying to get
the latino vote he played despacito on
his cell phone which
which some people said said was
pandering i don't give a [ __ ]
that doesn't bother me but the virgin
mary neck tattoo he had that was a
little far
that to me that's a little over the top
but uh the president was here you know
in here in california this week to talk
about the wildfires and of course say
some predictably [ __ ] up [ __ ] about
climate change
and in honor of his visit we made the
sky disgusting and orange
[Laughter]
and he
but it's a good thing he came because
the president
explained to us how fires work when
trees fall down
after about 18 months they get really
dry and they just explode
yeah that's what happened yeah also some
of the ones on the yellow brick road try
to grab you
trees got to watch out for trees people
but he also said you know he was talking
about coronavirus he said our covert
numbers would be
among the best if you take out the blue
states
yeah and america's headlines would sound
a lot more normal if you took out
florida
kidding florida i know you had a
hurricane love you in florida
but yeah then but you know the covet
thing he's partly responsible for it he
keeps having
these maskless rallies he had one this
week in nevada
sponsored by natural selection
and he said he said a lot of people
think the masks and by the way everybody
here's wearing masks
okay people in charge their authorities
were doing it right away
he said a lot of people don't think
masks are good they're not good and then
he was pressed on this
who doesn't think it's good he said
waiters
yeah because they have to keep pulling
the mask down before they spit in his
food
they hate that
but you know he as always he
contradicted his own people in the
health departments
and he said you know if a vaccine
doesn't doesn't kill the virus uh it's
gonna go away because of herd mentality
i'm not making that up he said herd
mentality will kill it
well it killed the republican party
maybe and finally he said that
the president said that someone in the
white house has
coveted but he said not anyone that was
near me
so we wish melania a speedy recovery